hello everyone here on the free curcum
Channel my name is Anu Kubo and I will
be your Guide to the wonderful world of
coding this tutorial is for anyone who
has never touch code before and would
like to get started with the basics such
as where to even write code in the first
place and how do we get text images and
even tables and lists showing up on our
web browsers for this we will focus on
getting the right tools we need in order
to get started as well as a fundamentals
course in the HTML language or in
non-code speak the thing that gives
structure to our websites and apps this
two-hour course is actually the very
beginning part of my full stack coding
course in which we go further and learn
how to style things up using CSS make
our code actually do things using
JavaScript learn how to work with apis
or in other words plugins such as this
core map API right here in our travel
app we built learn how to work with
databases as well as builds are secure
backends using node.js and express and
on how to build apps that we can sign up
log in and log out of while using
popular front-end libraries such as
react so that we have a full and
experienced resume that we write
together in which we can showcase
projects out of the 22 that we built
okay so what are we waiting for let's
get to it
so before we get started with anything
let's talk about the tools we'll be
using in order to help us code
the most important tool we developers
need is a way for us to write and edit
code
we could technically write our code in a
text editor like this but luckily for us
technology has evolved and we can now
write code in code editors that are
built specifically to make our lives
easier as developers by Auto indenting
lines and adding color-coded helpers for
readability
some code editors even go a step further
and give us prompts when they detect
that we have made an error this makes
debugging code a heck of a lot easier
there are so many current addresses out
there some are hosted on your computer
and some you can access online meaning
you don't have to download anything you
can just use it
it is also worth noting that is sup up
from a code editor is an IDE or
integrated development environment
it essentially does the same as a text
editor a code editor but also acts as a
compiler all in one space as well as a
bunch of other stuff
this tool is a bit too robust for what
we will be needing in this course but it
is worth knowing the difference between
each of these tools
today hybrids of these tools exist so it
is much harder to fit a specific
technology into one of these categories
there are many types of code editors out
there
as mentioned we 've ones that we can
download directly onto our computer and
ones that are hosted online
for this course I'll be showing you how
to use one that is downloaded onto your
computer I'm going to be using the code
editor vs code
I am doing this for no other reason than
I had to choose one but if you would
like you have all of these other code
editors Ides or hybrids of both to
choose from
for those of you who would like to get
coding straight away without downloading
anything onto your computer you also
have the option of these online code
editors please take a moment here to
decide which choice is right for you
okay so by now we should have our
preferred code editor of choice up and
running as mentioned in the previous
section I will be using vs code on my
Mac
this means I have downloaded it and it
should look like this on your computer
when it opens up
the next thing we need to decide is
where our project is going to live
a website essentially consists of a
bunch of files or organized together in
a particular structure you design
here we can see a project that holds my
HTML file another folder that holds my
style sheet or css files another folder
that holds my JavaScript files and a
folder that holds my images
don't worry if none of this makes sense
we will be building up a project called
my portfolio slowly throughout this
course starting with creating the folder
in this section
if you are like me and have downloaded
vs code you will have to store these
files locally on your computer
you can store them wherever you like
just make sure they are organized in the
same way inside your project folder
which we have called my Dash portfolio
on this occasion I want to store the
folder for my Dash portfolio on my
desktop so that we can see it visually
too
if you have chosen to use an online code
editor you will not need to do this as
your files will be hosted online along
with your project however I would still
strongly advise watching along so you
know how to do this in the future
so on my desktop I'm simply going to
press Ctrl and left click on my screen
and then create a new folder okay and
rename it to my Dash portfolio just like
so
next I'm going to open up vs code that I
just downloaded so it should look like
this and I'm going to open up that
folder I just created
so to do this I'm going to just select
open folder and navigate to my desktop
where I will find the my portfolio
folder that I just created
I'm just simply going to click on it and
open it up by pressing the blue open
button and there we go
that is now looking good
you will notice how I am keeping the
folder name in lower case this is
because many computers especially web
servers are case sensitive this means
that if you want to find a file in your
project and you use a capital when none
exists it might not work to be on the
safe side I recommend sticking to
lowercase when naming or folders and
image files in our project
this is also the case for having spaces
in the names
browsers web servers and programming
languages do not handle spaces in the
same way as each other causing potential
chaos
for example if you use spaces in your
file name some systems May treat the
file name as two file names and some
servers might even replace the areas in
your file names so the spaces with
percentage 20 instead it is for this
reason that I would strongly suggest
using a hyphen instead of a space when
naming files and folders
okay
and that's it we have created our
project folder next let's learn a little
bit about HTML so we can create our HTML
file for our web page
okay everyone and welcome to the first
coding section of this course in which
we will be learning about HTML in this
section we are going to get started with
the very basics of coding by looking at
the language that essentially started it
all for web development without it we
would not have the pretty pages that
make up things such as this very
platform you are currently viewing our
course videos on
to understand a little bit more about
how it all works I'll be starting off by
giving you a brief overview of where
HTML sits in context of a web page as
well as understand how it came about and
move on to a tutorial with interactive
questions and code examples in order to
learn how to use it the tutorial part of
this section will take up the majority
of this course
we will start off by learning what
exactly HTML is
understanding where it came from looking
at HTML elements understanding HTML
syntax or in other words it's structure
and then looking at HTML Anatomy once we
have grasp the basics of HTML and how to
use it we will be using everything we
have learned by building out a project
that we can be proud of we are doing
this as throughout this course I will be
giving you projects that you can choose
to put in your developer portfolio
these projects will be ones that I have
chosen in order to help you approach
potential hiring managers in a bid to
try and get you your first developer job
each of these projects will be appearing
to you at various points in this course
so while skipping lessons is optional I
would strongly recommend you watch each
lesson in order to fully build out your
portfolio to its most wonderful
action-packed self
okay so what are we waiting for let's
get to it
before we get to any coding at all let's
actually understand what HTML is
HTML stands for hypertext markup
language it is considered to be a
comparatively simple language that helps
create the building blocks that make up
web pages and apps we use today
we essentially use it to describe the
structure of web pages what I mean by
this is that we use it on a document
designed to be displayed in our web
browser by adding annotations that will
change what certain elements look like
think of it and the way a teacher marks
your work with a big fat red pen
they will make annotations on your text
in order for you to change it it might
be to change something like spelling or
it might also be to make a heading
larger or something bold
these annotations are not to be seen by
the end but we applied behind the scenes
if you will
same goes for applying markup language
in computer text processing you are
annotating a document that is
syntactically different to the existing
text
now what you cannot currently use HTML
to change the spelling of things you can
use it to transform tags into a heading
or make it bold as well as a bunch of
other things
in fact we can apply the hypertext
markup language or HTML to this boring
lump of text and make it look like an
actual recipe we see online
so we can take this and make it look
like this
so as you can see we have taken the text
made satin text bold made some text into
headings hyperlink some text and change
some text into a segregated paragraph As
we mentioned we have done this thanks to
annotating the document using hypertext
markup language or HTML
this mock-up looks like this
so here we can see the text and here we
can see the markup or more specifically
the hypertext markup language we
colloquially call HTML
let's have a look at some of these in
the next section
so we have now seen what the hypertext
markup language or HTML looks like in a
real life example let's break it down by
looking at one of these elements first
and understanding its syntax
syntax is just a fancy word for the
structure of statements in a computer
language and that is exactly what we're
going to be looking at we're going to be
looking at the structure of HTML
elements in the next four minutes I'm
going to really deep dive into HTML but
don't worry we're going to go through
all of these sections video by video
coming up next okay so bear with me this
will be a lot
this right here is what makes the text
in between it bold it is referred to as
an HTML element
almost all HTML elements will have an
opening tag and a closing tag like this
one we can also pair this with a
paragraph element that will make the
text below this appear to look more like
a standard paragraph
when writing like this so by using the
angle brackets in this fashion with a
slanty line or solidus to close the
element browsers know not to display
these HTML tags but use them to
interpret the content of the page
by mixing and matching these HTML
elements we are slowly starting to build
out what looks more like a recipe page
than a lump of text we originally saw
in fact we can mix and match over 100
different types of HTML elements here
are just some of the more popular ones
to our disposal
let's start by looking at the paragraph
element
the Syntax for the paragraph element
looks like this let's talk through this
in more detail
so first off we have the opening tab
HTML elements are defined by tags
written using angle brackets as we
touched on before
this opening tag tells our browser Hey
listen up an HTML element is about to
start
next we have the closing tag which is
just like the opening tag apart from
this slanty line or solidus this tells
our browser that the HTML element is now
finished any text after this tag should
not be applied the paragraph styling and
then of course we have the content
itself this is the text I want to apply
the paragraph styling to
it is in between the opening tag and the
closing tag
all together this is called a paragraph
element ta-da
and of course we have other elements an
interesting one is the heading element I
say this as there are six of them the H1
tag is the biggest heading and the H6
tag is the smallest heading you can use
the tags as a main heading for example
or a subheader in the browser The
Heading tags would look like this so
each of the tags would have a certain
size assigned to it what is interesting
about this is that giving texts and tags
gives it semantic meaning to the browser
meaning that the browser will read the
text with some kind of meaning
in this case the H1 tag will be treated
as the most important title on the page
I did also mention that most elements
have an opening and closing tag I say
most as some elements do not need both
this applies to the image element for
example
we use image elements embed images onto
our pages
image elements do this by a specific
attribute which is the source attribute
represented by this SRC right here that
takes the path to our image file
I have also chosen to include the
alternative attribute with a description
of what my image is
I say this as a choice but if you want
to make your website accessible to all
people it is something I would strongly
advise
this is because users who are visually
impaired will be able to use tools to
read out this alternative text to them
it also helps others know what the image
is all about if the file based to load
or if the path to your image file is
broken
we will go into more detail about
attributes and paths in the dedicated
section on image elements further in
this course
now we can also add comments to our code
that will not be visible in the browser
but will be visible to us and other
developers looking at our code
to add a comment that will not be
visible in the browser just like the
tags we need to put that text in between
two things
in this case it's the two bracket arrows
right here again making sure that these
syntax is identical to this example
now so far with these examples if we
just put them in a document open it in
the browser we would not be writing
about an HTML this is because we are yet
to do a few things which would include
building up the anatomy of an HTML
document we will do so in the next
section
in this course you will see me saving
files a lot by using a shortcut on vs
code vs code comes with many shortcuts
that are available to you here are just
a few of those for now I just want you
to focus on using the savings shortcut
which is essentially the command button
or control button depending on your
laptop plus the S button whilst on vs
code okay so if you are unsure of if
your file has been saved or not you
should see this white dot disappear
once that happens you know your file has
been saved we will be needing this file
to be saved as our next step will be to
view the latest version of that file in
the browser so if we already have that
page up we will need to refresh the
browser to see the latest version of it
okay so save the file using command s
and then we will go to the browser and
refresh the page that we are viewing in
there
save refresh save refresh you got it so
keep this in mind as we will be using
this in the next section and pretty much
all the lessons from now on until the
end of the JavaScript module
here is a basic file structure for when
working with an HTML file when we use
HTML elements outside of the correct
HTML structure we're not writing valid
HTML even if the browser can fix our
mistakes
the markup is only applied if the
elements are in the correct environment
we will go into what that environment is
in this section it is important to note
that for this course we are going to be
using the latest version of HTML and
that is HTML5 standard let's go ahead
and recreate this HTML file in our code
editors
so here I am on my code editor of choice
all I'm going to do is make sure I am in
my project which I have named my
portfolio and I am simply going to add a
new file like so
I'm going to choose to call it index
next by giving it the HTML extension my
code editor knows to treat this as an
HTML file you can and as many HTML files
as you wish your project naming them
whatever you want
just make sure to put dot HTML to tell
your code Editor to treat them as HTML
files
now that we have created our file let's
add some boilerplate code
so I'm just going to paste them in here
and talk you through it
the first tag I want to show you is this
right here it is a tag that tells the
browser that this is an HTML5 document
as mentioned there are previous older
versions of HTML so just be aware of
that on your journey as a web developer
the browser needs to know what version
of HTML the document is in order to
render it correctly
next we tell the browser where our HTML
is starting we are doing this as even
though we only have HTML in here for now
we can actually write CSS and JavaScript
in this document too something that I
will show you later down the line in
this course
we are going to be using this HTML
opening tag and closing tag as the root
of our document everything else that we
want to get picked up by the browser has
to live inside of it
next we have the head tag this is where
we store information mainly this is not
to be confused with a heading tab the
head tag will store information that is
not visible in the browser it is for
storing not displaying
you will see that in my head tag I have
a meta tag with a Char set attribute the
charset attribute specifies the
character encoding for the HTML document
this is not too important for now it
simply says that we want to cover most
of the characters and symbols in the
world so in other words we can handle
anything from Arabic to English to this
funky little guy right here
there are other meta tags we can use
also but for now let's keep it simple
and just use the ones we most need
next up we have our title tag this is
for naming our project we do this so we
can store what we want to call what we
are working on and we store this in the
head
so make sure it is in between the
opening tag and the closing tag of our
head
once again this is not a title we will
see in the browser however if you look
at the tab of the browser your project
is in you should be able to see it
it will also show up in search results
so for example in Google
next we have the body now this is where
the visible stuff will be
this is essentially where you can put
elements such as the ones we have
discussed already such as the paragraph
element The Heading elements the image
element and many more
we can also set the primary language for
our document
we can do so by simply adding the Lang
attribute to the opening HTML tag select
this this is useful as it will be
indexed more effectively by search
engines allowing you to appear in more
relevant search results
okay and there we have it
let's start deep diving into some more
elements next
we briefly touch on headings so far in
this HTML module however I would like to
take a breath to Deep dive into them a
little bit so you really get a good
grasp of what they are and what they are
used for
so once again the heading element comes
in six variations with the H1 element
being visually the biggest and the H6
heading being visually the smallest
each one has an opening tag and a
closing tag
in addition to this it also tells our
document which heading is the most
important behind the scenes so for
example if I was to give a web page an
H1 element our web page knows to treat
this as the most important title on the
page kind of like giving an essay its
title so we know what it's about
you should also only have one H1 element
on a web page hey you wouldn't name your
essay twice would you
after the H1 element you also should use
these subheadings in order meaning the
H2 element should come next and then the
H3 and so on but you can have multiple
subheadings of the same size again just
like when writing an essay so for
example this is good and this is not so
good
however there might be occasions where
you might see these conventions broken
in addition to this nesting multiple H1
elements was allowed in older versions
of the HTML standard however it was
never considered a best practice so just
keep that in mind
now you might be thinking oh this does
not look very fun
well don't worry we can actually change
what these headings look like using a
programming language called CSS
CSS will allow us to change the font
size of these headings but not only that
allows to change the color weight style
and much more we will be looking at CSS
right after the HTML module in this
course
another great and popular tax related
HMR element is the paragraph element it
is essentially this cute little p-tag
right here
the P element represents a paragraph or
in other words a block of text we can
use it to Bunch up text that goes
together so like this
this means if we put another paragraph
element after this one again with a
bunch of text it will appear spaced out
from the other one now it does not
matter what line you put the text on
after all if you put all of this on one
line it's kind of hard to read
so you can put the text on multiple
lines in your code editor if you want it
will not affect how it looks like in the
browser
you might see p elements written like
this or like this or other ways too both
of these approaches I am showing you are
valid just like with the heading element
we can add CSS or in other words styling
to change the default styling of the
paragraph element meaning you can change
this spacing amount but not only that we
can change the font size the color the
line spacing of the text and so much
more
we will be doing that in the CSS part of
this course
so by now we have had a very quick look
at how do I offer elements this included
the paragraph element and heading
element now let's put what we learned
into practice by creating an online
recipe for macaroni and cheese
so the first thing we're going to do is
think about the website structure I
would like my recipe page to have a
heading followed by some sort of
description an ideal element to hold the
content of a description would be a
paragraph element
after this I want to use a smaller
heading as a subtitle to let people know
that this section is for the ingredients
necessary
after that I will need some sort of list
to list out all the ingredients and next
another subheading followed by the
instructions in a numbered fashion
wonderful I think this is a good start
now let's get to actually creating this
with HTML
so first off I'm going to ask you to
create another folder on your desktop
this time I want you to call it HTML
project one
once you have done that I would like you
to use what we have learned in order to
create an HTML file in the project
called index.html as well as add the
correct boilerplate to it in order to
get started
please post here and have a go at doing
this once you are done let's go through
the solution to getting this done
together
okay so what I would do is well first
off I will just open up vs code so
please go ahead and do that and now I'm
just going to open up that folder we
just made so that directory just made so
just go ahead and on your desktop find
it click on it and open it up so there
we go there's our empty directory or in
other words empty folder and all I'm
going to do is just create that
index.html file so to do this I'm just
going to click on here and I'm going to
call the file index and I'm going to
give it the HTML extension so dot HTML
in order to let our code editor know to
treat this like an HTML file
wonderful now that we have that let's
get going with our project
so first off I'm just going to put in my
boilerplate code I've just taken this
from the previous project I have not
remembered it please don't try and
memorize this okay just make sure that
you have your HTML element your header
element and your body element and the
body element is essentially what's going
to hold all our visible elements next
also make sure you have the meta tag up
here as well so that we can see all the
characters that we need okay so our
project is looking good at the moment
there is a few things we need to do
outside of the meta chart set the other
thing we have in this head element is
the title that is going to hold the
title of our project it will not be
visible in the browser once again it
will be visible in the tag and will also
be visible as a title in Google search
results
okay so let's go ahead and call this
something I'm going to go ahead and call
it recipe as that is what best describes
what this webpage is gonna hold the
first one I'm going to put in is the H1
element
by choosing the H1 element I am also
doing something behind the scenes
search engines indexing our web pages
will consider the contents of the H1
heading more important than that of an
H2 heading for example without any
headings at all our page will perform
poorly in terms of search ability online
or in other words poorly in terms of SEO
one other thing that is happening is
that we are defining this as the most
important heading on the page for screen
readers used by the visually impaired if
no headings are provided users of the
screen reader will not be able to jump
from heading to heading and instead will
be forced to read all of the text on the
page as a lump of text
once we have a heading I'm going to move
on to using a paragraph element for our
description
so here is what our paragraph element
will look like
now we can make certain words or phrases
more important in the paragraph by using
these strong element inside of this
paragraph element
we would do so with the strong tag
Now when using a screen reader this word
will be read out in a different tone of
voice
now we can also visually see this has
been applied bold styling however if we
do not want the screen reader to read
this out differently and just want to
make this word look bold we can use the
ball tag instead other things we can do
is emphasize using the EM element once
again the screen reader will use a
different tone for this and if we just
want to make it look italic we can use
the eye element like so
and great I think we should now check
this out in the browser so what it looks
like in the browser next before doing
anything don't forget to save this file
once again a shortcut to save this file
is to press command s on your keyboard
so please go ahead and do that you will
see the little dot disappear at the top
of the file tab now in order to actually
view this file on the internet you're
going to have to get the actual file so
go ahead and left click on it and then
just go ahead and copy the path so this
one right here that first one get up
your browser and paste it like so and
there we have it we can view that whole
file in a browser you're viewing your
local file on your computer on your
browser right now
great now let's add a subheading for our
list of ingredients
so by now we know that a subheading is
any heading below our H1 heading I'm
going to choose the H2 heading element
for this
and wonderful now it's time to look at
lists in the next section
in this section I want to talk to you a
little bit about the readability and
presentability of code
for this in HTML I'm going to talk about
indentation and spacing indentation and
spacing should be consistent throughout
your code we can use either the four
space or two space indentation in HTML
this means that each nested element
should be indented exactly once inside
their parent tag by either four spaces
or two spaces okay so as you can see
here is what it looked like when it's
all beautiful and neat with four spaces
of indentation
as you can probably see everything is a
bunch more readable everything is kind
of lumped together and you can see which
opening tag and which closing tag go
together just like the top article tag
and bottom article tag
this is in contrast to Bad Code like
this
I mean you can hardly tell which tag is
starting where what the parent elements
are which makes this overall a lot less
readable than the previous version
trust me this would make it much more
difficult when debugging and trying to
find tags that go together in the future
another thing you should do is format
lines so for example in this case you'll
see that the text in my paragraph
element is too long I would suggest
splitting it out into multiple lines
okay so kind of like this okay so this
was just a quick break to talk about
indentation and spacing please keep an
eye on this moving forward
in this section we're going to learn how
to make a list such as this section
right here that shows the ingredients of
a recipe as well as this list right here
a ordered list that shows these steps in
making our wonderful macaroni and cheese
list elements are actually made up of at
least two elements a wrapping element
and the individual list item elements
themselves
your list can be an unordered list like
this one meaning that the order will not
matter or an order list an unordered
list is however perfect for listing out
the items that we need to buy in order
to make macaroni and cheese as the order
in which we buy them doesn't matter the
wrapping element for an unordered list
is this UL element right here
and of course we have the ordered list
an ordered list will give order to our
list items so just like we see here we
get one two three the element in order
to make an ordered list is Ol as you can
see by the wrapping element right here
as a default the order list comes
numbered like so but we can also change
it to be lettered no matter which list
type you choose so the unorder list or
the order list it should have the list
item elements inside once again these
Syntax for a list item looks like this
it comes with an opening tag and a
closing tag that will take content
inside the list item element in this
case it is some text but it can also be
much more let's have a look at this in
code okay so the first thing we're going
to add is as we discuss an unordered
list add the ingredients as the
ingredients do not need to be in a
specific order right because it doesn't
matter what order we buy them in we
might already have some in the kitchen
or we might need to buy some more it
really doesn't matter to us so let's get
up our unordered list element which we
now know is made up by these two tags
with UL in them like this next let's
open it up because it's gonna have to
take some list items so let's put in our
list item elements they are made up of
the LI tags and opening and closing tag
and we're going to put in seven of them
so there we go I've just gone ahead and
created all seven each with an opening
tag and a closing tag that will take
content inside of each one okay so as a
reminder the content does not have to be
just text it could be images it could be
a bunch of elements nested inside of
each other that really is up to us
in this case however I'm just going to
put some text okay so let's go ahead and
do that I'm just going to paste it in
from somewhere I have written previously
so I'm just going to put it in for all
seven of these list items I'm just
putting in some text and it's the
ingredients for macaroni and cheese
okay
so there we go we now need to save this
page so save it pressing command s and
let's check out what this looks like in
the browser don't forget that we of
course need to refresh our browser to
see those changes and great there is our
unordered list now that we have finished
this let's move on to make our ordered
list
so once again just like before I'm just
going to put in an H2 title okay so this
is a subheading that I'm going to put in
it's just going to say how to make it
and underneath that is where we're going
to put our orders list element so the
wrapping element that will take list
item elements so ol is the tag that
we're going to use is going to have an
opening and a closing tag and inside of
it I'm just going to go ahead and put in
three list item elements this time so
please go ahead and do the same put in
three and I'm just going to paste in
these steps into making macaroni and
cheese so they're pretty simple it's
just going to be brewing a pot of water
to boil
next I'm just going to paste in a longer
sentence okay so you will see I have
formatted it to put it on different
lines so we can see it and finally just
the final this item element and that's
going to say add cheese and macaroni and
that's it how simple is that so simple
recipe we're not going to win any
Michelin stars for this but we will have
a cool recipe web page that we have
built so once again don't forget to save
this page pressing command s and then go
to your browser and refresh it so we can
see the latest version of the document
and ta-da there we have it
our order list is now on there too
in this next section we're going to look
at links links are great as they allow
us to essentially link to other pages on
our website link to specific Parts on a
web page that we built link outside of
the webpage that we built all together
and some are completely new on the
Internet or even open up a prompt to
email someone or call them a link
element syntax looks like an a element
like this and stands for anchor so if
you hear someone calling in anchor link
do not be surprised let's look at what
makes up a link element now so we have
the opening and closing anchor tags in
between these Tags I'm going to put some
text so that our browser knows that if
we click on this text it will take us
somewhere so for example I could put the
words my YouTube channel
here is what this will now look like in
the browser so it just looks like some
text for now nothing special
at the moment of course if we click on
this link it won't do anything we have
not given it enough information about
what we want to happen if we click it
and why we want this link to take us
to do this we need to Define where we
want the link to take us using the href
attribute we put the href attribute in
the opening tag now in the value if we
want to link it to my YouTube channel I
would take the full path to my channel
and put it here okay so now let's save
this refresh and check it out and
wonderful if we click on the link we are
now taken to my YouTube channel page
we can also use links to open up a mail
option or option 2 call all you need to
do is put the mail to prefix followed by
semicolons and the email address you
want to populate to your email recipient
address with so here we go and if we
save this file and go to the browser and
refresh you will see another link
if we click on this link however a
prompted email we will show up we can
also add a hyperlink to prompt calling
so once again we will get the anchor tag
but this time for the value for the href
we will add the tell prefix like this
followed by a phone number
this isn't my number by the way so
please don't go calling this random
number and apologies to the owner of
this number in advance
this time if we save this page and go to
the browse and hit refresh then click on
the link a prompt for calling that
number will show up
as mentioned we can also link to
specific places on our web page but this
time using IDs
for this you'd first need to create the
element you want to link to let's say
this is a heading for example so here we
have my heading element as you can see
it has an ID that says other recipes and
here we have my link element which has a
href to the ID okay so hash here
represents an ID and we're looking for
the ID of other recipes
so here we have my heading element as we
know using two H1 elements isn't really
best practice but this is just an
example that I want to show you in terms
of how to scroll to another main header
so for now I'm just going to allow it
and here we have my link element
I would have to give my a-links opening
tag the attribute of href and then pass
through the ID so hash means ID add the
element we want to link to
so by giving it the value of hashtag
other recipes I am now saying I want to
link to my H1 element with the ID of
other recipes
and if I want my page to scroll to the
element with the idea of other recipes I
would have to give the link the href of
the ID right
so let's grab the ID and let's stick it
up here great I am now just gonna add an
unordered list here in order to give
length to the page
just so that the scroll is more obvious
but when we scroll to this H1 element
and now let's check it out
so save the page first and let's go over
to the browser and hit refresh I'm just
going to go ahead and increase the size
of this page so that it is more obvious
everyone for when we scroll so just
increase the zoom on yours too if you
need so now let's test it out I'm just
going to click on here and wonderful
we managed to scroll to the H1 element
we have now finished building out our
recipe project using HTML so give
yourself a round of applause I think we
did great
now we have not covered IDs in full just
yet there is a bunch more stuff we can
do with them this was just a quick
taster we will cover them in more detail
later on in this course
so by now we know that we can build web
pages to link to external resources or
link them to specific elements we built
in order to scroll to them visibly on
our web page another thing we can do
with the link element is take a user to
a specific page that we built on our
site
to do this let's go back to our project
that we called my portfolio
and let's have a look at our project
structure first
so say we are on the index HTML page
right here and we want to access another
HTML page one of these Pages for example
we would have to write a path from where
we are currently in the project tree to
this folder called pages and then to the
file we want out of these two this is
how you would do so so bear in mind we
are starting from the index HTML page we
are going to go into the folder called
Pages using the forward slash I'm going
to enter that folder and pick out a file
I want to show let's just say that file
that I want to show is called abami HTML
so let's just specify that in that path
Now by clicking on this element we will
be taken to the about me page
okay let's test it out to see if what
I'm saying is true
so first off let's make sure we are
opening the correct project so let's go
ahead and get the project my portfolio
so here we have our project
I'm going to go ahead and create a
directory or folder for our extra pages
called pages
and in it I'm going to create one file
called about dash me.html making sure to
not have a space but have a dash
and paste in some boilerplate code as
well as change the title of the page so
that we know which page we are dealing
with of course don't forget to save this
page now on the home page let's go ahead
and add this link that we saw on this
slide okay so just added this like so
now let's open up the index HTML file
not the about me HTML file so save the
page and copy the path to the index.html
file and paste it into your browser now
don't forget to reload the page in order
to get the latest documents and let's go
ahead and click here and ta-da we are on
the about me page it as works now let's
have a quick look at the parts to this
file here in the browser okay so as this
project is stored on my computer I am
starting at the root so going into a
directory called users on my computer
then going into a directory called Annie
Kubo then into another directory called
desktop and then into the directory that
we made for my portfolio enter the Pages
directory I just made and then getting
the about me HTML file to show up in our
browser of course when you host your
projects online after buying your own
domain this will not look the same I
will most likely look something like
this but we will leave that to the end
now what if we want to link back to the
home page from the about me page
well we need to navigate back to do this
I'll go one level back in the tree or in
other words out of the pages folder we
need these two dots like this followed
by the Slash and then get the file we
want to show
so let's test it out so back in my
project I'm just going to go to the
about me page so I'm just going to go
right here and add an anchor link with
the href and as the part I'm going to go
back so the two does mean we go out of
the folder and then I'm going to
essentially specify which file we want
to show okay so that's all I have done
so now let's check it out
so let's go back to our browser hit
refresh click on the go to about me page
and here we are we're on the about me
page and here's the link we just made
that says go to the home page
so let's test it out let's check that
this takes us back to the home page and
it does okay we are on the index HTML
page that lives in my portfolio and
amazing this is looking great so the
slashes that we see in the path are
essentially us jumping either backwards
or forwards in the tree of my project
from folder to folder essentially
imagine each of the folders in this tree
as a slash and if you follow the path to
your next location and pick up a slant
it's like you've just added it to the
path that you are constructing okay so
you're just picking them up like a train
same thing for if you are leaving the
folders you will need to use the dot dot
to go all the way back to your spot in
the tree where the train is safe to
proceed to get to its destination
got it now let's do another one
imagine you are in this park called
Contact HTML what part would you have to
put in your href in order to get to the
about me page have a think about it
using this graphic of our project tree
right here please post here and do that
and once you are ready just hit play
well as we are on the same location so
in the pages folder we don't need any
slashes our train literally stops pretty
much at the destination
so we just put the file name now let's
test it out so first let's create a
contact page in the Pages directory so
contact.html and I'm just going to put
in some boilerplate code and once again
just change the title to say contact
like we just did before with the about
me page now in the contact page I'm just
going to put another link so another
anchor tag and I'm just going to put go
to the about me page and of course we
need to link this to that page so I'm
going to use the href and I'm just going
to put the about me page about Dash
me.html Okay so just like we did an
exercise if we click on this link it
should take me to the about me page so
this one right here
and actually in here I'm just going to
put in another link so from the about me
page I also want to be able to go to the
contact page so let's go ahead and add
an a link and then I'm just going to put
go to the contacts me page and as the
href I'm just going to put
contacts.html so exactly what our
contact page is called
great now let's check it out so save
those files go back to the browser and
hit refresh
and now click on the about me page link
and great we see both those links so we
go to the home page or we go to the
newly made contact me page so let's
click that and wait we are on the
contact me page we see the title in the
browser tab we also see the path going
to the Pages directory and getting the
contact.html page and we see that link
that we made on that page which takes us
to the about me page and let's test this
one out too and wonderful that's exactly
where it goes once again as you can see
by the tab name and the path that we
have here
okay great so hopefully this explains a
little bit about how you would navigate
from page to page on a website once you
have this down let's carry on
we are now going to move on from looking
at how we can manipulate text in HTML
and look at how we can add images to our
web pages we have already touched on
images before but for good practice
let's recap what we have learned so far
about this wonderful element
in the introduction to HTML we learned
that unlike most HTML elements the image
element is one of the ones that uses a
self-closing tag meaning it only needs
one tag like this
we also learned that it is the source
attribute that contains the path to the
image we want to embed
this image can be in our project folder
and we can navigate to it by writing a
path to the correct file so we can use
the URL address of an image that is
hosted online
just be aware that if the person or
company hosting that image chooses to
take it offline you will no longer have
an image here to display you will see
this broken URL icon right here instead
you will also see the alternative text
if you choose to add that to your image
element
the alt attribute is super helpful in
occasions like this when they're linked
to the images broken or the image won't
load as it will allow the user to know
roughly what it was about
it is also wonderful for the visually
impaired who might use a screen reader
to see what is on a web page
let's try to put an image on the about
me page of our portfolio by putting an
image of ourselves
okay so I'm going to choose to store an
image in my project all I'm going to do
is find an image of me so I'm going to
choose this Square jpeg so just make
sure yours is also a JPEG or a PNG file
and next I'm actually going to create a
directory so making sure you're on the
root of the project so the same level as
the index HTML file just go ahead and
create a directory called images
and it's going to store all our image
files from now on
so there we go I just created a
directory it's on the same level as the
Pages directory and the index HTML file
so let's go ahead and put an image in
there I'm simply going to drag an image
in for my computer like this and drop it
in wonderful
so there we have it that is now done and
now let's go to the about me page and
once again I'm just going to use this
code right here so from the slide and
I'm just going to paste it in like so
so we now know that we need to get the
path to this image and assign it to the
source attribute and I'm also going to
provide some alternative text just in
case this doesn't work for whatever
reason or just to make it accessible for
everyone so I'm just going to put an
image of Amir Cuba you can choose to put
whatever you wish
now the part to this well once again
let's look at the project tree so I need
to go back to the root of the project so
I need these two dots and then I need to
go into the images directory so I need
to go into the folder I'm jumping into
the folder and I'm just going to put the
name of the file that I want to access
okay so that's it now if we save
everything that we've done so far and
just refresh the browser making sure
you're on the about me page amazing you
will see that image it's unselt at the
moment so it might be very big or it
might be very small but we will work on
that when it comes to the styling
section of this course for now this is
looking good let's carry on if you are
having issues with this at any point the
final code will be attached to this
lesson so please go check it out
in this section I want to show you how
to work with tables this is going to
involve a lot of nested elements so our
HTML elements are getting a bit more
complex
by the end of this lesson you will have
built something like this but don't
worry we will build up to it step by
step starting with a tiny table first
so the simplest table elements can take
three types of elements the table row
element the table header element and the
table data element we would start off by
creating the table element which will
wrap up all our content nicely so it all
stays together
inside I need to start off by making
some table rows so let's say we want our
table to have three horizontal rows I
would add three table row Elements which
look like this
so now we have some rows I next need to
decide what kind of columns I'm going to
have
let's say I want my first column to
contain last names and my second column
to contain last names
I would need to add the table header
element to tell our browser we want this
to be the name of the column it would
look like this
now that we have defined the columns
names we can fill out the rest of our
data using the table data element it
would look like this
and that's it that's a table in its
simplest format
if you would like to give your table
more semantic meaning for the browser
you can also Define that the first table
row belongs to the table's head by
wrapping it in a t head element and the
rest in a table body element so t-body
visually it will not change what you see
in the browser but it will help your
website SEO as well as screen readers
know what is going on
okay
cool got it good because now we are
about to put all of this into practice
by implementing a simple table onto our
portfolio project
okay so back on the about me page I want
you to put in a table in order to
organize our future projects this is
what I want the end result to look like
so three columns one for the hyperlink
to the project which we will leave the
href blank for now another column for
the title of the project and another
column for a quick description of what
the project is about and what
technologies we used for it
for those of you thinking wait this is a
pretty ugly table are you sure we want
to put this on our portfolio don't worry
the fun styling stuff is yet to be done
for now let's just get building using
the basic building blocks we have at our
disposal okay so what are we waiting for
let's get to it please have a go at
building this Yourself by pausing here
once you have built your table unpause
and we will go through my chosen
solution together
okay so what I would do is well on the
about me page I would start off with my
wrapper element as mentioned this will
be the table element as that's going to
hold or our child elements together so
go ahead and create your table elements
so there we go there is an opening tag
and a closing tag and in here well I'm
going to do the more advanced version of
the table so what I'm going to do is put
in a t head element as the first child
on my table
so the T head element looks like this
and it's essentially going to hold our
head up for our table and then let's put
the tea body element as the second child
of the table element and that's going to
hold the rest okay
great so one child and a second child
next I'm going to create a table Row for
the head
so for this I'm going to use the TR
element once again it has an opening tag
and a closing tag and once we do that
I'm just going to put in two of these in
the body as well so that we have three
table rows in total Okay so let's go
ahead and do that I'm going to put in
the second table Rook here and then just
put in another one great I'm just going
to open them up because we're going to
put content into here
now in my first table row I'm going to
use the table header element and we're
going to have three of these because we
want to have three columns or
essentially three table headers and then
I'm going to mirror that in the other
table rows however with table data
elements so that we can sort data for
each of our columns so the first table
header is going to have project the
second is going to have title and the
third is going to have description as
that is what I want my columns to be
called
so there we go so now if I refresh the
page so save your project and refresh
the page I'm just going to make this
bigger ta-da you should see right at the
bottom are three table column names or
in other words table header names
great so now let's get to putting in the
data
so let's go ahead and do that back on my
project in the first table data element
well I'm just going to put project one
and in the second table this element I'm
going to put the title of that project
is the one we made is the macaroni and
cheese recipe and then I'm just going to
put in a short description of that
project okay so this is what a table is
going to look like it's going to have a
project it's going to have the title and
it's also going to have a short
description
wonderful and let's do the same for the
other one for this one I'm just going to
put project two and this is going to be
our table tennis leaderboard so let's go
ahead and put table tennis leaderboard
okay and then again let's just put in a
description it's very long so I'm just
going to format it a little bit better
to make this more readable this will not
be shown in the browser this is for us
just to be able to see this in our
project right now so there we go
and there we have it that is our table
I'm just going to put some more text in
here just to Pat it out of it
wonderful so now ta-da that is what our
table looks like it's got three rows two
for the data and one for the column I
think this looks great
now I'm just gonna go ahead and add one
final table row just to kind of prepare
us for what we are going to be putting
in in the future so let's go ahead and
make that table row let's put in a table
data element with project three and of
course we haven't made this yet so I'm
going to put TBD as the project title as
well as TBD for the project description
but essentially we're going to add a
bunch more projects into here so just so
you know what this looks like I've gone
ahead and added another table row and
wonderful
so this is looking great I'm really
happy with how this is looking so far of
course without any styling yet the last
thing I want to do is just wrap the
First Column entries in a links so an
anchor links because we're going to want
to link to this in the future at the
moment I'm just going to leave an empty
href attribute okay so this will just
give this the appearance of links but
without actually going anywhere so just
do that for all the a elements like so
and great so we have now created some
links of course they will not work but
visually at least this column looks like
links this is the final look that I want
to aim for
wonderful
okay so I think we are done with this
project for now let's move on
now that we have covered some of the
many text related HTML elements let's
move on to the fun stuff which allows us
to create shapes add colors to our
website starting with the content
division element or in other words the
dev
I like to think of the div as a
beautiful being that could be anything
you want it to be we can get the div a
height we can give it a whip and we can
give it a background color using CSS or
another one styling which we will cover
in the next section we can also use it
in a very basic form without styling to
hold other elements together
so for example we can create a div put a
heading in it and put a paragraph in it
and now these two elements will be
gripped together
so you might think great so with this
div I can now group together pieces of
information to start adding structure to
my web page well not to throw a spanner
in the works but you are partially
correct the div should only be used if
the section element article element nav
element header element or footer element
don't apply why you ask this is because
these elements all have semantic meaning
and will be interpreted by your browser
to be an element that holds a section an
element that holds an article an element
an element that is the header of your
website and the footer of your website
djib does not have this it's like a
mysterious ghost
let's have a look at some elements with
semantic meaning in the next section
by now we should know the elements that
make up a web page can have semantic
meaning
this means that the web browser will see
them and recognize what the element is
meant for this makes it good for users
of assistive Technologies like screen
readers and they are also good for SEO
we have the header element which
represents quite literally a header this
can hold things such as your website's
logo a search bar and other things
typically seen in a website's top
element
the header element is not to be confused
with the head element which as we now
know holds the website's metadata so all
the invisible stuff
just like the header element we have the
footer element which literally
represents the footer of your web page
you can put anything you want in the
footer however typically you would see
something like information about the
company copyright data or any links that
you would want to give the website
viewer
next up we have the nav element which
represents the navigation bar on your
website it will usually contain a menu
or a list that will allow you to
navigate between all the pages on your
website we also have the section element
which represents a standard section of a
document
sections should have headings in them
after all think of when you read a book
it would be kind of strange to see a new
section that didn't have a header for
you to know what the text in this
section was about right without this
heading the element will not appear in
the document outline if you do not want
to put a heading element in the section
perhaps it's not really a section you
are after perhaps a div would work
better on this occasion
the last populous sectioning element I
want to cover is the article element an
article element can represent things
such as newspaper articles a blog entry
a product card a user submit a comment
or a forum post amongst other things
just as with this section the article
element should include a heading element
nested inside of it
now I must stress there are many more
semantic sectioning elements to your
disposal I have simply covered the most
popular ones or the ones that might be a
bit tricky however there are all these
other ones as well at the time of
recording if you have the time I would
suggest doing a quick Google of each if
you are interested I feel most are
pretty self-explanatory so you don't
feel like Googling it's fine let's carry
on
so by now we have covered the most
popular text-based HTML elements as well
as some semantic sectioning elements and
the dip I am now going to ask you to put
all of your knowledge to the test by
building out this table tennis
leaderboard
unlike in the first project I'm going to
leave you two at this time
the goal is to create a directory or in
other words folder called HTML project
to create an HTML page to go into the
project with the correct boilerplate
code and then use the elements we have
covered to recreate what we visually see
here
you are of course free to refer to the
previous lessons we did in this course
so far and don't worry that is in no way
cheating no one is expecting you to
memorize these things even I still copy
and paste HTML boilerplate code
so once again this project will utilize
everything we have learned so far as
well as three new elements that I
briefly listed out in the semantic
sectioning elements video okay so these
three will be used in this project
section it is a hairline element which
is essentially a line an element that
will allow us to write captions and the
figure element as well so please go
ahead and do some Googling by yourself
on these three this is an excellent
lesson in Googling and once you are
ready please have a go at this
once you are happy with your project and
you want to see how I would choose to
create this page please click on the
next video and remember there is no one
way to create this page there are
literally thousands of ways you could do
it so get going and I will see you soon
okay so now I'm going to show you the
solution to how I personally would
create a table tennis leaderboard that
looks like this
okay so I'm excited to show you first
things I'm just going to create a new
folder on my desktop I'm going to call
it HTML project two just like we decided
in the previous video
okay and once I've done that I'm just
going to open it up in vs code so I'm
just going to open that folder so please
go ahead and do the same open it up in
your code editors just simply by
pressing open folder finding that
project on your desktop
clicking on it and opening it up
so great I'm now in my project there is
nothing in here at the moment so let's
put in our first file
so all I'm going to do is click on here
and create an indexed HTML page not
forgetting to give it that HTML
extension to let our code editor know to
treat this as an HTML file okay so go
ahead and do that and now I'm just going
to put in my boilerplate code
so as we know for our boilerplate code
we can just copy paste it so that's what
I've done I've pasted it from another
project and now I'm going to put in the
title of my project this title will not
be visible to us okay in the browser it
will be visible in the tab of the
browser and it will be visible if you
uploaded this onto the internet and
search for it in Google
okay
great so I'm gonna go ahead and call
this table tennis so please go ahead and
do the same
great before we get to putting in
anything in our body elements I just
want to open this up in the browser so
we can see what it looks like so all I'm
going to do is just left click on the
index.html document right here and then
copy the path and then go to my browser
and just paste in that URL like so so
there we go that is what index.html page
looks like and as you will see you can
see table tennis in the tab name great
now let's get to adding some elements in
the body elements so first off I'm just
going to put an H1 element and for my H1
element I'm just going to put table
tennis just like so
so now if we say that file and refresh
the page this is what it should look
like we can see that H1 element in our
browsers
great
next let's move on by putting an H2
element in here
so in my H2 element this is going to be
a sub heading and all I'm going to do is
put in some text so I'm going to put
classroom tournament leaderboard just
like so and now if we save this file and
go ahead and look in the browser so
let's refresh the browser you will see
classroom tournament leaderboard showing
up
wonderful we have an H1 element and we
have an H2 element so a subheading
element let's carry on
next let's get to creating some semantic
sectioning in here and first off I'm
just going to start off with creating a
table
so here's my table element it is a
wrapping element that's going to take a
bunch of other elements in order to
create our table the first one being the
T head element so just go ahead and put
in a t-head element and then put in a
cheap body element for the rest of our
table rows okay
so our table heads element well we know
this has to contain a row so let's go
ahead and put that in so that is my
whole table head and in my table row
well I'm going to Define our table
headings one is going to be a position
heading so just go ahead and put
position one is going to be for the name
of the person playing in the tournament
that that is going to be for if they won
or not and the fourth is going to be if
they lost or not so it's going to be a
count of one and lost tournaments so if
we refresh the page in our browser that
is what it looks like at the moment we
have created four table headings or in
other words four table columns
great
this is looking good next I'm just going
to put in some table rows that are in
the body so essentially for our data our
first table row is going to have a table
data element so I'm just mirroring the
table heading so I'm going to have four
okay so we're essentially going to
create table rows for these columns well
our first table data cell is going to
have the position so we're going to have
position one then we're going to have
the name of the player who's in position
one it's going to be my name Gomez and
she's gonna have one five and lost zero
so save this and refresh the browser and
amazing we have just created our first
table row to go on our table
let's go ahead and create another one
next
okay now let's create our next table row
so we know how to do this now just go
ahead and use the TR tags to create a
table row and then in here I'm going to
put four table data elements because we
want to essentially put data for a
position and name a one and a lost value
so let's go ahead and do that in fact
I'm just going to copy this as we're
going to have a few of these so we have
one table row let's go ahead and paste
another so we have two and three and
four and five okay and let's do it so my
first single row I'm going to put
position two the name is going to be
Mohammed Leroy and he's going to have
won four and lost one okay next as
position three I'm going to have the
name of let's go with Patricia Bennett
okay so that's the name I have chosen
Patricia Bennett and she is one three
and lost two position four is going to
go to Sam Lehmann he has won two and
lost three position five is gonna go to
Young
Lee he has one won and lost four and
then let's do position six as well and
this person is Astrid Genevieve and she
has won zero and lost five
and I think that's it so we just need
six so let's save that let's go back to
our browser and refresh and ta-da there
is our classroom tournament leaderboard
we have just completed our table this is
looking great
so let's carry on
the next thing I want to do is just put
in a line and for this I'm going to use
the HR element that I did say to Google
previously so if you Googled it you
would know that the results would look
like this and it's just a nice way to
split this out okay
wonderful so we have just split this out
by creating a line thanks to the HR
element which looks like this
let's move on
the next thing I'm going to ask you to
do is put in another subheading this is
going to be smaller than the other
subheading we have so I'm going to use
an H3 element for this so please go
ahead and do the same just use your H3
element and put in the title or the
subtitle of rules of table tennis and a
colon just like so so just like I have
now the rules of table tennis this was
an ordered list
so I'm going to choose use the ol
element so here are my ol tags and
inside I'm going to have to put list
elements now first this element is going
to contain the texts of games are played
two and then I'm going to make a bold
number so I'm using the Bold
tags or if I want to give this semantic
meaning to the browser I can use the
strong tags so each was fine to use okay
whichever one you use is okay and then
I'm just going to put space and points
great
our next item is going to have the text
of alternative
serves every two points are mandatory
and this time I'm going to put the
number 2 in strong so let's just get up
on strong tags and I'm just going to put
the number two in there great let's just
minimize this for now
let's make our third list element so our
third list element this one is going to
have the text of make sure to toss the
all straight up when serving
okay so that is my thirdest item let's
check it out so say that page on refresh
and wonderful so we've just made our
rules of table tennis it is an ordered
list and you can see the 10 and 2 are in
bold so that is looking great let's
carry on
now what else do we need to create well
I just want to create a paragraph
element that's going to take some text
and that text is going to be in italic
so I'm going to use the I element for
this okay you could have also used the
EM element if you wanted to give the
page semantic meaning but I'm just going
to give it the I element from now so
again each one is good
in here I'm going to put official
rules can be found on the international
making sure to spell International
correctly table tennis website so that
is now going to appear italic on our
page and I'm going to actually hyperlink
here so to do this I need to get here
and put it in some eighties or the
anchor link and next I need to give the
anchor link First tag so let's just
space this out a little bit making sure
that the indentation is correct
so let's just make sure that those eye
tags are on the same level and the P
tags are on the same level
next to make this link work I need to
give the first tag of the a link and
href attribute and I'm just going to go
ahead and type in the URL to the actual
International table tennis website so
this is it for all of those curious okay
that is the link to the international
table tennis website
great so now if I refresh this amazing
we get some tags in italic and the here
is hyperlinked and if we click on it it
does take us to the official table
tennis page how cool is that let's carry
on
let's just make the official Spell
correctly first
and great
next I'm going to put in another line so
let's go ahead and use our HR element
again
now I'm going to put another subheading
so I'm going to use my H3 element again
and this time I'm going to have the game
set up so game setup is going to be my
subtitle now I'm going to have a p
element in here and this is essentially
just going to give us some more
information so it's just going to say
the game should be set up as per the
table tennis tournament
at Liga Pro okay so just giving some
insight into how the table tenants table
should be set up and finally I'm going
to show a picture of this so I'm going
to use the figure element this is
another element that I asked you to
Google in the previous video so
hopefully you did that and this figure
element okay so for this we're going to
actually have to put in an image element
in here so go ahead and do the same it's
a self-closing tag and then for this
image we can have a figure caption so
that is my figure caption element the
third element that I asked you to Google
in the previous video so hopefully you
did that as well
great
now in my fig caption I want this to
appear in italics so I can use the eye
element or I can use the EM element if
you want to give it semantic meaning
that is up to you and I'm just going to
give this image taken from Wikipedia
okay so that is what I'm going to do and
I'm actually going to hyperlink
Wikipedia too so just whack in Wikipedia
here and as the opening tag of my a
element I need to give it the href
attribute along with the link to
Wikipedia which is this for table tense
great
okay so this is looking good let's go
ahead and find an image so just whack in
that Wikipedia URL and then copy the
image address to this table tennis image
and then as the source of this just put
in the URL to that so as long as that
web page exists as long as that picture
exists this picture should appear in our
own project so just go ahead and do that
or you can put a picture in here okay
that is up to you just like we did
previously you can put a picture in here
that you uploaded and made an image
directory you could have done it both
ways both ways are absolutely fine so I
hope you did either of those or if not
let me know what you did
finally I'm going to put an alternative
tag to this image element so I'm just
going to space it out so we can read it
a little bit better and put alt as the
attribute and then some alternative text
which in this case I'm going to have
table tennis tournament as
great
okay so this is looking wonderful so far
shall we check it out on the browser I'm
just going to space this out a little
bit so it's more readable so essentially
I am just putting everything on new
lines and making sure that each element
is essentially in line with each other
in terms of indentation okay
so that we go each nested element is
more indented than the other
wonderful
this is looking great that is my whole
URL
so now let's recap what we've done so we
add in an H3 element as a subheading we
added a p element as a subheading so now
this is a lot I think we've done well
one other thing we probably should do as
all of this game setup is essentially
associated with each other we should
probably put it in a section element to
hold it all together and we can do that
as we have an H3 element so we have a
title so let's go ahead and create our
section element so our section element
looks like this and in here we're
essentially going to store all of that
that's associated with game setup so
there we go that is it and finally let's
format it to make sure that all the tags
are indented on the same level and that
each nested element has indentation as
well
great let's do the same for the rules of
table tennis I'm just going to put that
in its own section so there we go and
now let's format it so that each nested
element is on the right level and great
so now let's check it out save that page
refresh and there we go that is what our
table tennis leaderboard looks like it
looks amazing it looks exactly like we
wanted you to it looks exactly like the
image that I showed you at the beginning
I hope you also have this and if you've
done it in any other way please do share
your code with me on Twitter please
either paste a link to your codepen or a
picture of your code I would love to see
foreign
s I'm going to be focusing on creating
forms forms are a fantastic way of
submitting a bunch of information
together
we use them on sites to get back
feedback write in or even sign up and
log in
forms are made up of a bunch of elements
that are nested in between the two form
tags
some typical tags that can live inside
the form element are the input elements
label elements or field set elements
however you can technically put in any
elements you like
the form opening tag can take certain
attributes it can take the action
attribute which takes a URL that will
take care of the form's submission as
well as the method which takes the HTTP
method to submit to the form
don't worry about this for now as this
is an advanced topic we will cover later
or you need to know for now is that the
input with the type submit is how you
would essentially trigger the action
attribute with the method attribute to
submit form data when you wish
the input element with the type submit
generally does not need a label element
associated with it this is unlike an
email input for example which would
benefit from having a label element
in the next section we are going to look
at the other types of input types as
well as the various attributes that we
can use
how an input tag looks and works wholly
depends on the type attribute and the
value you assigned to it
by default if no type is provided it
will take the form of a text input to
use the text type here is a full list of
the different types available to us
I'm not going to go through all of them
as some will be self-explanatory but to
help you get the gist of how input types
work let's whiz through the most popular
ones now
try to remember them as there will be an
exercise straight after this
so let's start with the text input in
fact the Ember element like I said will
default to the text type even if we
don't Supply it with a type so this is
an easy one to remember we can also add
other attributes to the text input for
example we can control what the minimum
length of text and or maximum length of
text can be with the mid length and max
length attributes
we can also add a placeholder to provide
a hint as to what type of text we want
in here we can also make it required
with the required attribute or we can
make it read only
if we start working with JavaScript we
might want to use the name and value of
the input so we can work with it in a
more readable way this means that we can
send over the value of what we put into
the input along with the input's name if
we have loads and loads of inputs in our
form
in this case it would be first name Anya
next let's look at the button type if we
take the input element and assign the
type button to it it will look like this
so a button at the moment and of course
won't have any functionality but it
certainly does look like a button
doesn't it we can also add a value in
order to change the text inside the
button too
another attribute that goes in the
button element can be disabled this will
visually disable the button and prevent
users from being able to interact with
it
now what if we switch this to a checkbox
type
well we got a checkbox visually that we
can choose to tick or untick it can also
take a value however this time this is
not displayed in the browser or in other
words on a client side it is used on the
server side so that we can take the
value of the checkbox and use it for our
Computing needs along with the checkbox
name
this means that when the form is
submitted the data name value pair will
be subscribe newsletter if no value is
supplied the new value pair would simply
be subscribe on if the checkbox is
ticked
next up let's see what happens if we
change this to be a color type
the Empire element then takes the form
of a Color Picker as we can see here we
can click on the element and then drag
the cursor to select say color which
will generate an RGB value for it or a
hsl value or a hex value
we can also choose what color we want to
start on by assigning a value to the
input element
now let's move on to the date type by
supplying the date type we are creating
an input that looks like this so
essentially a date pickup with a year
month and day when active in supporting
browsers this input is fun as we can of
course set a default value using the
value attribute but we can also set a
Min and Max state
this means you will not be able to
select dates in the date picker outside
of this range and if we change this to
date time local an option to select the
time will show up to
next up let's look at the email type now
this might look like a normal text input
but it has certain validation parameters
meaning it won't accept the field unless
you give it a at sign and a domain we
can actually change these validation
parameters by using the pattern
attribute and using regex
regex or regular expressions are rules
that govern which sequence of characters
come up in as such there is much to
learn on Regis which we will not be
covering in this course but if you would
like to know more about how to write
these rules please check it out in the
link below
in addition to the pattern attribute we
can also have other attributes such as
max length Min length multiple for
multiple email addresses and placeholder
for displaying some placeholder text
next up we have the radio type you might
be thinking hold on this is just the
checkbox type of the circle well there
is one big difference only one radio
button in a given group can be selected
at any point in time this is different
to the checkbox in which you can select
multiple check boxes
here is what a group of radio inputs can
look like and behave like we can even
give them label elements and Link them
to the respective input with the full
attribute which correlates to the radio
elements ID
the range input is another fun one in
that it has this cool slider we can set
a bin and max range for the slider as
well as hardcore the value it is
currently at with the value attribute if
we want to increment the slider to our
biggest steps we can do that quite
literally with the step attribute too
and finally the last input type I want
to show you is the submit type which we
briefly touched on already
just like the button type we can change
the text and the button using the value
attribute however we should only use the
submit type to actually trigger
submitting the form the form element and
the input or the type submit are linked
if you want to have other uses for the
button inside the form and write your
own custom JavaScript such as to update
the value of an input dynamically or
select something I would suggest using
the button type
and that's it we have just covered the
most popular input types let's move on
with some exercises
foreign
everything we have learned so far in the
last section on inputs in order to
really hone in our skills all about
inputs so we're going to have three
exercises we're gonna have to replicate
what we see visually with code
so to do this let's create a kind of
scratch bar that we're going to work
with
so all I'm going to do on my desktop is
create a project that I'm going to call
classwork so there we go there we have
our classwork folder and now let's open
it up in vs code
so go over to vs code and find that
project
so go ahead and find it on your desktop
click on it and open it up
okay great and now what do we do well we
need to create our index HTML file so go
ahead and create an index HTML file
making sure to use the HTML extension
okay so that code editor knows to treat
this as an HTML file and there we go
step two is going to be to add the
boilerplate code so please paste some in
from a previous project and let's just
call this scratch pad for now
great please go ahead and save this file
now let's open it on the browser by
grabbing the path and pasting it in the
browser like we've been doing so far
great
now that we have that done let's
continue
so now that our setup is done let's have
a look at the exercises that we need to
replicate
so for exercise one I want you to create
an input that will take an email and
it's obviously a company email that
takes a certain domain
so please take that into account and
also take into account the fact that
this has to be an email
so three things here and you also have a
placeholder visible so that is also
something you're going to have to add
and of course we also have a submit
button that will submit our attempt at
putting in an email
so let's go ahead and do it
I'm going to lead you to this I will
however lead you with the knowledge that
all of this has to come in a form
element okay otherwise it will not work
as intended when submitting okay so here
we have the form element now please go
ahead and make sure all your work is
done in between these two tags so I'm
going to leave you here please pause
here and unpause when you're ready to go
through my solution together
thank you
okay so what I would do is and of course
this is just my solution there are many
ways to do this is first off I would
create an input element so let's go
ahead and create one like so so it is
just one tag like this and I'm gonna go
ahead and give this the type of you
guessed it email
so there we go
so now if we look in the browser and hit
refresh I'm just going to make this a
little bit bigger we have the input with
a type of email right so it looks like a
text type but we know it has a different
semantic meaning and different
functionality
so now let's go back as we just add a
few more things into this input element
and also I'm also going to add a label
element as we did see that in the
example and This is 40 below input so
let's link it up and how do we link it
up using for an ID so let's add the four
attribute to the label and let's add the
ID attribute to the input so let's go
ahead and give this the ID of emot input
you can go ahead and call it whatever
you wish and now let's grab that ID and
just paste it into the four attribute on
the label so now both are linked up okay
we've just linked it up using before an
ID attributes great let's go ahead and
add some tags into the label I'm going
to just go ahead and put please use a
udemy.com email
okay just like so so now if we look in
here ta-da the label is now showing up
this is looking good
the next thing I want to work on is the
placeholder so to add a placeholder I
would do this on the input tag it's
going to minimize this for us and I'm
going to put placeholder and I'm just
going to put Ania at udemy.com of course
I don't work at udemy so this is fake
let's go check this works
um great we will now see some
placeholder text that will be replaced
as soon as we start typing
now let's go ahead and add something
else visually and that is the submit
button
so we know by now that we don't use an
actual button we're going to use an
input with a type of submit and that
input will trigger submitting the form
as both are linked so let's go ahead and
put an input with a type of submit so
just like that and refresh the page in
order to see it as a default the value
of this is submit but we can change it
with a value attribute so let's go ahead
and do that I'm just going to put that
in like so okay so there we go
however right now I can go ahead and put
Dan at dan'sworld.com and sign in and
that will submit okay so that has
technically worked it is refreshed it's
technically submitted we haven't put any
extra functionality at the moment so our
form by default is just refreshing the
page but we know that we need this real
udemy address right so we would like an
error message shown up to do this we
need to add the pattern attribute
so my pattern attribute well I'm just
going to add the string of Plus at
udemy.com and now I am saying that I
want the domain to be udemy.com for the
email I'm just going to space this out
so it looks a little bit more readable
at the moment okay so just go ahead and
do the same
great
so we have just added the pattern make
sure there's a DOT there let's check it
out so now I'm just going to refresh
this page to load the changes and type
Dan at dan'sworld.com and try to sign in
we get that error message
so there we go we have essentially
blocked other email addresses from
signing up
just like when we do a d that won't work
it will say there's no email present so
now we've officially made some
validation happen on our email
great so the form is not submitting it's
not refreshing so we are being stopped
from signing in
wonderful so we have now completed
exercise one this is how I would solve
it however if you have done it another
way then please do share that with me on
Twitter I would absolutely love to see
okay so look forward to seeing your
Solutions over there
in the meantime let's move on to
exercise number two
in exercise two I would like you to
build this range input that will
essentially allow us to increment the
steps by 20 in order to get from 0 to
100 to percent of this range okay so
that's all that I would like you to do
for this exercise please go ahead and do
this once again the main body will be
zero and the max value will be 100 and I
want the increment to be in 20s in
addition to this I would like the
default to start right here okay so make
sure to make that happen as well as well
as add a label to the input
so please go ahead and do this and once
you are happy with your solution we'll
go through a solution together
okay so first off I would just start off
by putting an input element and
assigning it the type of range so a
range that is very smooth in its
movement so there's a few things that we
need to change
so we need this to increment in 20. so
let's go ahead and add the attribute of
step with the value of 20 so that if we
now refresh our page our range input
will now look and behave like this so
not as smooth but it's incrementing in
20. so let's carry on
the next thing I want to do is just give
it a Min and a max value so I'm going to
send meant to be 0 and Max to be 100 so
just like this if we actually change
this to be an 80 well I'm just going to
show you what happens I'll step that
implements in 20 has four steps as 4
times 20 makes 80 so that's four steps
but we want this to be a hundred so
let's just go back and change it to be
100. great so as default this will be
100 but I just wanted to emphasize that
by putting it here
next I also want to code these start
values so I want this to be at 20
because I want it to appear around about
here so that's exactly where it is I
just hard-coded 20.
and finally let's just give it a label
so I'm just going to use the label
element for this by creating a label
element and then putting in some text
this text is going to be volume and now
let's link the label to the input using
the for an ID attributes so four I'm
going to put volume input and for the ID
I'm going to put the same so volume
input so great they are now linked so
we've done it we have our input it's
looking exactly like the exercise at the
beginning now you should actually put
this in a form element like I said so if
you want to submit this eventually two
things you will need are the form
elements like so as a wrapping element
as well as the input or the type of
submit okay so if you would like to
submit the value of this input with the
type of range those two things will be
needed great so this looks great I hope
you've enjoyed this exercise please do
share your solution with me on Twitter
via the link below if you've done this
another way I would absolutely love to
see
and finally for the third and final
exercise I want you to essentially build
out this form that will allow us to pick
one of the three options about how our
experience was at a theme park so this
is what I want you to build you're gonna
have to think of a way to pick out one
option out of a bunch of options and
then submit it via a form
so please think about this pause here
and I'm excited to see how you do this
by yourself and then go through a
solution together
so see you in a bit
okay so I would do is well here we have
our form first off I'm just going to
create an H1 element okay because this
was bigger than a label so I'm going to
use the H1 element for this and I'm
going to put how was your time at Happy
Land
okay so that's what my H1 element is
going to look like now we can have this
in the form that is absolutely fine okay
so I've decided to put in the form and
next we need to decide what kind of
input type we're going to use for the
multiple choices
the type I'm going to use is Radio why
radio and why not checkbox this is
because the radio will allow us to
choose one of the three options and not
allow us to select multiple options like
the checkbox type
so in the input I'm of course going to
have the type radio but I'm also going
to give it a label the label is going to
say bad and I'm going to link it to the
above input we'll do for an ID
attributes so let's link them up by the
same name let's have bad input and let's
put the ID as bad input as well great
so there we go and for good measure I'm
just going to give this a name just in
case you know in the future we want to
link this up to JavaScript we don't
really need to do this now but I think
it's good practice to start adding names
to these types of inputs so as a name
I'm just going to give this the name of
experience okay because it's all related
to one experience
so well done if you choose to add that
name attribute there you're already
thinking about the future
so let's check out what this looks like
at the moment great so we've got our bad
input let's let's create another input
so let's go ahead and use the input
element and create a label for it this
is going to say okay let's link them up
using the for and ID attributes and I'm
going to put OK input here and give this
the ID of ok input
great
now let's also give this the type of
radio and leads essentially link it to
the other input by the name attribute of
experience
okay so once again when it comes to
JavaScript this will be important for
when we want to essentially get the
value of our inputs for the type
gradient in addition to having this name
attribute for when it comes to work with
JavaScript we're also going to have to
give both of these a value so remember a
key value pair made up of the name and
value so I'm just going to give the top
one the value band and the second one
the value is okay
wonderful once again these are important
for the key value pair for when we start
working with JavaScript it's not nearly
necessary now so if you don't add them
don't worry and now the final input
let's go ahead and create that input
element let's go ahead and create a
label element this one's going to have
the text of good and let's look them up
with the for and ID attributes let's
call this Good input and give this the
idea of good input and give this a type
radio and again give it the
name of experience and value of good
wonderful we are now done
so this is how it looks like on the
radio inputs we can also have one
checked as a default if we want simply
by adding the checked attribute so I'm
just going to go ahead and do it on this
one and that will mean that this one is
checked by default and of course we can
change it and we are not selecting
multiple ones as you will notice right
now
wait the final thing we need to do is
just add an input with a type of submit
that has the visual appearance of a
button but essentially it will allow us
to submit this form if we click on it
along with the value of the one we've
chosen hopefully in the future when we
hook this up in JavaScript
and there we go once again I hope you
had fun with these exercises please do
share them with me on Twitter because I
would love to see what you have done
with yours otherwise let's continue
in this next section we're going to talk
about the select element in order to
create one ourselves
this select element allows us to select
an option from a drop down menu and
looks like this
so we have this select element which we
will name with the name attribute for
when we want to pick it out with our
JavaScript and then we have all these
option elements nested inside of it now
each option element has a value again
for when we need to pick it up with our
JavaScript and then the text of what we
want to see visually in the browser in
between the two option tags
this select element is usually
accompanied by a label element which is
linked to the select element with the
for and ID attributes
so that is the code for writing a select
drop down and this is how it behaves it
is for this reason that it could be wise
to have the first option element contain
new tags please choose an option with no
value so just an empty string to
represent nothing being chosen even if
we click on it but this is not required
one other thing we can do is hard code
these selected value by using the
selected attribute on the option element
on this select element itself we can
have many attributes some of these
include the disabled attribute that
looks like this the required attribute
or the multiple attribute to be able to
select more than one option
got it good now it's time for a little
exercise
okay so let's get to practicing what we
learned in the previous section by
building a select drop down
so this time we're not going to be using
snacks let's go ahead and recreate what
we see on a e-commerce site by having a
drop down of sizes so we're going to
have extra small small medium large
extra large and extra extra large okay
so let's go ahead and do it first off
we're going to start off the label right
so there we have our label and this
label is going to say select your size
and next under here we're gonna have
this select of course
so it's going to have an opening tag and
a closing tag and I'm just going to
pause here and ask you to complete the
rest of this exercise next
so once again it's a drop down for an
e-commerce site that will allow us to
pick sizes for our garment okay pause
here and let's go to the solution in a
bit
okay before we do anything I'm just
going to link up the label to the select
with the for an ID attributes as a
reminder I'm just linking the label to
the select or this attribute so let's
make sure that these are the same I'm
going to have a size list and size list
right here for the id2 okay so there we
go and now let's add some options so my
first option is just going to have the
value of blank I'm just going to leave
it a blank string and this is going to
say please
select your option
so there we go our first option is
essentially a blank value and our
section option is going to have the text
extra small next we're going to have
another option or the size small and
then we're going to have a third option
let's actually just paste in a few with
medium large and extra large and then
one more for extra extra large
Grace
so there we have it visually this will
look fine but we know we have more to do
we need to add a value to this as well
so that when it comes to picking this up
JavaScript we are prepared
so let's go ahead and give this the
value so I'm just going to give this a
readable value for when we need to pick
this out later on and it's just going to
be the string XS this value I'm going to
give the value of s here I'm going to
put an M for this one I'm just going to
put an L for this one I'm going to put
the value of XL and you guessed it for
the last one I'm just going to put the
value of x Excel and there we go
so this is looking good and for good
measure we of course we know we need to
give the select a name and let's go
ahead and call this sizes so once again
this is for eventually picking it out
with JavaScript
so now if we look in here
we can select our size and we can see
the options
now if I was to change this to be extra
small like so and Save
you will see that that has changed
however I'm just going to put that back
to the way it was if I put extra small
here
nothing will change okay once again this
is because this is for our JavaScript
and should actually technically be
written as one word or two words
connected by a dash in order for this
value to get picked up okay
so there we go that is some knowledge
for you for when it comes to picking
stuff up without JavaScript later on
and wonderful so that is our select
exercise done I hope you enjoyed it
let's move on
now I just want to take a quick break to
talk to you about the inspector
Google Chrome's inspect tool can give us
a lot of information about what is going
on in our browser in fact it can show us
exactly what code we are sending to the
browser and in what state
I'm going to show you how to inspect
this browser to our browser right here
now
so here we are back on our select
exercise that we just did and here is
the select drop down that we just made
now if I go ahead and left click on the
browser while pressing Ctrl on my laptop
you will see this show up I'm simply
going to click on the inspect tool in
order to get up this inspect tool for us
this will show us many tabs including
the elements tab which will show us the
elements making up our web page that we
are viewing
as you will see this is exactly our
document that we're working on so you
will see the HTML element you will see
the title element that we give our
document and you will also see the body
tag in which we added a label element
and the select element with all the
options that we just coded just right
here
so this is pretty cool and we can now
hover over so we can choose to select
items in our browser
which will show us exactly which element
we are selecting or we can select them
here so just click on that and select
maybe this label and this will show you
that label in the browser along with the
size of that element along with any
styling that has been applied to it at
the moment there has not been any
styling added by us this is just the
default styling under the Styles tab
what is also cool is that we get a
console we will not be using this now
but we will be using this in the
JavaScript section very heavily so just
keep that in mind so this is the inspect
tool it's really useful for us as
developers now and especially in the
future
now I feel like I've saved this one to
show you as I am really fond of the data
attribute and I want to talk to you
about how you can make custom-ish
attributes
to give us flexibility HTML5 allows us
to store extra information on standard
HTML elements using the data attribute
the Syntax for it looks like this we can
of course have data or we can have data
Dash and put in whatever word we want to
make a custom attribute now why would we
want this well we can have a div that's
served like a card so here we go here is
my div styled like a card okay so I
can't wait to show you how to style
stuff in the CSS part of this course but
for now just stick with me
now say I want to flip this card and
display some text such as a question and
two possible answers we can actually
store that information on the div itself
without actually visually seeing it we
will do so like this
so we can have data question data option
one or data option two
so now that information is stored on the
div but we can't see it with our eyes on
the div
so for example we can sort a data
question attribute that says what color
are the carrots okay we can also store
another attribute so let's have data
Dash option one which will give us an
option of let's say blue and then we can
also have data option two that will give
us a second option as well that we are
storing on that element let's go with
orange so that's a lot of information
that's custom information that I am
essentially putting on an element
now with the magic of JavaScript we can
then get these attributes and show them
and they did on the click of the element
but we will leave that magic for when
the time is right
now it is also worth noting that this
information is not fully secret and is
still on the client we just can't see it
visually however if we inspect the
browser like we just learned and look at
the HTML document that makes it up we
can see that information here
if you really want something to be
hidden you would have to store it on a
server and retrieve it when you need
in this section I want to talk to you
about how you can add little notes in
your code that won't affect anything in
the browser but why do this well as
developers we might want to annotate
things we have done things we need to do
or simply leave notes for another
developer that comes along in the form
of an explainer or to do action item
for beginners I would strongly recommend
annotating or in other words adding
pseudocode as often as possible
all you need to do is make sure the text
you and add is in between these
these you can add this manually or in vs
code you can highlight the text and
press command forward slash
so for example here we have some code if
I wanted to add a reminder on the form
that I want to add another input I can
simply write some text that says to do
and then I would comment out by
highlighting the code and pressing
command forward slash obvious code
so that's what I've done or you can
manually add the characters you see at
the beginning and end of this line
another thing you can do as mentioned is
put reminders so add code to yourself so
for example here I'm going to remember
the pattern can take regex Google this
later so this is great for as a beginner
you can leave yourself little notes
about what certain parts of code does or
little reminders about what we learned
in that lesson so once again two copies
out just highlight it all and press
command forward slash on vs code and
finally we can also add little reminders
to other developers too
so for example if you're sharing this
code base with someone and you think
they might not know the intention of
some code that you put you could leave
them a note so for example I have put
this input will trigger the action on
the form when provided because of course
we have not provided an action on this
form by at least this lets someone know
that we have thought about it
okay great
so there we go hope this was useful that
is how you can comment that code so that
it's not visible in the browser
foreign
that's it for the HTML section let's
recap what we have learned
so wheeler what exactly HTML is or
hypertext markup language and how we can
use it
we also learned how to create our first
HTML page using the correct anatomy and
use it to create a recipe page together
using popular text elements we then
learned about how to navigate between
Pages or do different things altogether
as well as about semantic sectioning and
elements we also learned about The
Versatile dip which is essentially a
great shell to create anything and use
our knowledge to create a table tennis
leaderboard
after that we looked at forms and input
options as well as how to create our own
costume-ish attributes
phew so we learned a lot
now where to go next
well I would really strongly recommend
going over everything we have learned so
far and try built out another recipe
page okay so this time perhaps a
different recipe than the one we
previously did and add it to your
portfolio
next I would try build a Wikipedia page
clone so similar to the format of the
table tennis leaderboard I would like
you to use your knowledge of everything
you've learned so far in order to build
a Wikipedia page next I would also like
you to try practice your Googling we did
a little bit of practice in Googling so
far in this tutorial but you're going to
be needing it a lot more as you progress
positive
develop in CSS especially there are many
many properties and attributes that
exist so being able to Google them
correctly is definitely a skill that we
should acquire
if you have time I would also suggest
looking at the remaining HTML elements
that we did not look at in this course
as mentioned at the beginning there are
over a hundred so please take some time
here if you want to familiarize yourself
with the ones that we did not cover
I do think most are pretty
self-explanatory so if you don't want to
do this don't worry
next I would suggest also playing around
the inspector that we are now acquainted
with
please go ahead and search random pages
on the internet and inspect them using
the tool seeing what they have under the
hood
and finally let's get ready for some CSS
this part is going to be great as we're
actually going to learn how to make
stuff look pretty in our browsers so see
you then